david we'll follow it thank you texas
republican senator ted cruz is mocking
state democratic lawmakers who
have fled to washington in order to try
to scuttle republican election reform
efforts
in texas at the state house the
democrats are requesting care packages
be sent to them including soda and salsa
toiletries and money crews responded
with a tweet asking
no miller light the reference to a
picture showing the lawmakers traveling
to washington on a private plane
all surrounding a case of beer
let's bring in senior political analyst
brit hume tonight good evening brett i
wanted to talk about a couple of new
polls
uh abc washington post poll came out
with some interesting numbers one is the
outlook on the country's future this
optimism pessimism
has really shifted in recent weeks uh 45
optimistic 55 pessimistic and then you
look at the approval rating
for uh the president on specific issues
and obviously covet
he's at 63 percent approval but you look
at crime
gun violence immigration down in the
high
30s your thought on this turnabout
well partly i think brett it's the
fading of the honeymoon period you know
every administration starts out with
high hopes high hopes in the public
and they tend to fade with time because
not everything is promised gets
delivered and in this case
enormous promises were made a very
ambitious agenda
only part of which has been enacted and
much of which may be in trouble
in addition of course you have concrete
things like the the
increase in prices pointing to an
outbreak serious outbreak of inflation
those duration we don't yet know you
have lawlessness on the border which has
been obvious
and about which nothing's of any
consequence seems to be happening being
done
and then of course there's lawlessness
in the major cities and that's something
that people
find frightening and do not want to put
up with plus
of course there's the sense that you
know that
that china's on the rise still we don't
seem to have checked china and so forth
so there's a lot of concrete reasons for
this i think
contributing to a moot and of course i
should add to that brett
the fact that covert cases are rising
that always frightens people i'm not
sure
cases is the best way to measure that
but people i think are obviously worried
about
you know a new round of shutdowns and
mask mandates some which appear to be
happening
you know brit the president obviously
receives uh some pretty good press
overall uh from the media uh but there
have been a couple of answers recently
at a town hall
also a reporter's question where he's
kind of snapped at them or said
something where people weren't following
it
there's a couple of examples in recent
days
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
covet if you have
these vaccinations the question is
whether or not
we should be in a position where you uh
um
are why can't the the
the experts say we know
that this virus is in fact uh um
uh is it it's going to be uh or assuming
we
we know why all the drugs approved or
not temporarily approved but permanently
approved
are there people who in the democratic
party
are there people in the republican party
who think we're sucking the blood out of
kids
you know it's just some answers that
media didn't make a big deal
out of them but made you scratch your
head well that second one you showed
there brett was pretty dramatic
and it you know the man obviously had
lost his train of thought and
couldn't recover it and stammered around
for a little while
these are signs of senility which is a
common thing in elderly people and biden
like me is certainly elderly but i think
it's
becoming increasingly obvious that this
is the case
and i can't believe that people who see
that who are not already committed to
him in one way or another or committed
against him
don't look at that and find it alarming
that uh you know at a time when their
worries are increasing
there's the polling showing that you
know the
pessimism in the country is increasing
they see the president of the united
states losing his train of thought and
unable to
to blurt out a coherent answer to a
question it's i think
people find it disturbing and makes them
wonder about the future
all right brit as always thank you hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else